in this video we're going to try to
solve the equation three times X plus
one minus X is equal to nine and like
always I encourage you to pause this
video and try to work through this on
your own but the emphasis of this video
is to not just get to the right answer
but to really understand what's
happening when we do algebraically valid
operations on this on either side of
this equation all right so let's begin
so the first thing that my brain wants
to do and we've talked about this before
there's many different ways to often
solve an equation but my brain wants to
simplify and the first thing that looks
a little bit hairy here is I have three
times the expression X plus one and so I
might be able to simplify that if I
multiply 3 times X and 3 times one and
so if I did that I would get 3 X plus 3
minus X minus X is equal to 9 and so the
key here is that the left-hand side of
the second equation is equivalent to the
left-hand side of the top equation and
so if the left-hand side of the top
equation is equal to 9 well so the
left-hand side of this bottom equation
is going to be equal to 9 as well
another way to think about it is if the
entire top equation is true the entire
bottom equation must be true and vice
versa but let's keep going so what's the
next thing that we could do here if
we're at least just trying to simplify
the left-hand side well my brain
immediately sees I have 3 X's here and
then I want to take away an X right over
there so if I have 3 X's and then I take
away an X how many X's do I have well
then I have 2 X's and then I still have
that plus 3 plus 3 is equal to 9 and so
once again this left expression is
equivalent to this left expression which
is equivalent to this top left
expression and if any one of these
equations are true that must mean that
all of these equations are true but we
could keep going now the next thing I
like to do is isolate the X terms on one
side so I want to have a left side that
just has this 2x there well the way to
do that is I would have to subtract 3
from the left side but as we know
anything that we add or subtract or
multiply or divide by on one side of the
equation we have to do on the other side
of the equation
so I'll subtract three right over there
and why does that make sense
well if 2x plus three is truly equal to
nine then if I take 3 away from 2x plus
3 if I just take 3 away it's not
necessarily going to be equal to 9
anymore so I have to take 3 away from 9
in order for the equivalence of both
sides of the equation to be true and so
what do I get
well then 3 and negative 3 cancel out
and on the left hand side I'm just left
with the 2x and on the right hand side I
have equals 9 minus 3 is equal to 6 now
I keep emphasizing because really that's
the point of this video that 2x equals 6
is an equivalent equation to 3 times X
plus 1 minus X equals 9 because we've
done these algebraically valid
operations we'd be able to maintain the
equality and we've been able to say look
if 2x is equal to 6 then we know that 3
times X plus 1 minus X is equal to 9 and
if this top equation is true then we
also know that this last equation is
true but when our and the homestretch
what can we do to solve for X well if we
just want to isolate an X here on the
left hand side as you can imagine we can
divide the left-hand side by 2 but if we
divide the left-hand side by 2 in order
to maintain this equality we have to
divide the right-hand side by 2 remember
equation it has it has the word equality
and or at least the first part of the
word equality in it we have if we
multiply divide add or subtract to one
side then we have to do on the other
side and so we are left with X is equal
to 6 divided by 2x is equal to 3 and we
have solved it and really x equals 3
continues to be an equation and so the
equation x equals 3 is going to be true
if this top equation is true and this
top equation is going to be true if the
equation x equals 3 is going to be true
now let me finish off with a little bit
of an interesting challenge for you if I
have 5x is equal to 6x one temptation
might be it kind of looks like this last
step we had over here and so why don't
we divide both sides by a common factor
and so maybe we could divide both sides
here by X
this is five times X and this is six
times X and what would we get if we did
that let's see we would get we would get
five is equal to six which it clearly is
not equal to six but what just happened
here
why did is it is it the fact that five X
can never be equal to 6 X and we did
algebraically valid operations and we
got five equals six or did we do
something wrong
pause this video and think about it well
some of you might have realized that if
X is an arbitrary nonzero number and you
know that you could divide by X but what
if X is 0 if X is 0 you can't divide by
0 and so that's actually what's going on
here because if you do algebraically
valid operations you will actually see
that this is a case where X is going to
have to be equal to 0 so let me rewrite
it so this is 5x is equal to 6x even
though it looks a lot like this last
step that we had in the first equation
and you're tempted to immediately kind
of knee-jerk to divide you have to
realize that I have an X term on both
sides or X terms on both sides let me
combine them so I could subtract 5x from
both sides or I could subtract 6x from
both sides let me subtract 5x from both
sides and then see what happens and we
are going to get on the left hand side
5x minus 5x is 0 and then that's equal
to 6x minus 5x is equal to X so we get
the solution for that original equation
5x is equal to 6x is indeed x equals 0
so the big takeaway here is to
appreciate the equivalence of these
equations if you do algebraically valid
operations and hopefully it's trying to
make some intuitive sense why certain
operations are valid and why other
operations are not valid but if you're
do valid operations it's really saying
that each step of your solution each of
those equations are equivalent to the
equations before it if one of them is
true then the others are true but if you
do an algebraically invalid operation
like you're dividing by X and X could be
equal to 0 then you can D you can start
running into problems